-The weirdos,
the many weirdos who tried
to help Donald Trump
overthrow the election are
in major legal
and financial trouble.
Trump is refusing
to help Rudy Giuliani
pay his legal bills
and MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell,
who's also been sued
for defamation,
had yet another meltdown
at a so-called Cyber Symposium.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Before we get to all that,
the big news in politics
right now, of course,
is the resignation of New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo,
who's slinking away in disgrace
after a long run
as one of the most corrupt
and cynical bullies in politics,
not to mention the host of the
weirdest kids' show in history.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
Terrifying man.
You know, it's hard to soothe
the soul of a nation
when you sound like
Chazz Palminteri's stuntman.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, a report
by the attorney general found
that Cuomo sexually harassed
11 women.
And let's not forget,
his administration also
covered up the COVID death toll
in nursing homes.
It's got to be the worst thing
he's covered up
since his nipples.
[ Laughter ]
I guess they also knew
how bad things were
and they were trying
to get the hell out of there.
[ Laughter ]
Those things like
porcupine quills.
They attack
when they're threatened.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, when even your
nipples are trying to escape,
you know you're in a bad place.
Maybe that's why he started
wearing a blanket,
like he was just rescued
from the Miracle on the Hudson.
[ Laughter ]
Look at him. Is he trying
to pull a "Mrs. Doubtfire"?
I wouldn't be surprised
if Cuomo pretended
to be the British nanny
so he could hang around
after he resigns.
He just has to make sure he
doesn't also take his fake name
from the front page
of the newspaper.
[ English accent ]
Oh, hello, my name is Mrs...
Andrew Cuomo.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, no, wait!
I mean, it's Mrs...
Disgraced Governor.
Oh, dear.
Don't mind the nipples.
They're just frightened.
[ Laughter ]
And when
he announced
his resignation yesterday,
Cuomo tried to explain away
his actions
by claiming he didn't realize
he was doing anything wrong.
-In my mind, I've never crossed
the line with anyone.
But, I didn't realize
the extent to which
the line has been redrawn.
-First of all, that's such
a ridiculous excuse.
You're telling us
you didn't know
what you were doing was wrong?
What's next,
you going to tell us
you didn't know what day it was?
You don't get to blame
the line for moving
when you're the one
who crossed it.
Although, I will say,
if you live in New York,
you've probably heard
that before.
Cuomo sounds like he's trying
to talk a traffic cop
out of giving him a ticket
for parking in a fire lane.
[ As Cuomo ]
I swear, when I parked,
the line was over here.
Now you're telling me
it's over here?
Come on,
you're breaking my balls!
[ Laughter ]
It's a very
George Costanza way of excusing
your [bleep] behavior.
[ As Costanza ]
The line, Jerry, it moved!
[ Laughter ]
They moved the line!
Oh, it moved, baby!
[ Laughter ]
And it turned out I crossed it!
[ As Seinfeld ]
You know what this means.
You're a line-crosser.
[ As Costanza ]
Lines here, lines there!
I'm crossing lines all
over the place!
[ Laughter ]
[ As Elaine ] Have I
got a line for you.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Seinfeld ]
Well, get in line!
[ As Elaine ]
I was with Puddy last night
and he used
the line.
[ As Seinfeld ]
He used the line?!
[ As Costanza ]
I thought using the line
crossed the line!
[ As Elaine ]
Not my line.
[ As Seinfeld ]
Now, that's where I
draw the line.
[ "Seinfeld" theme sting ]
[ Laughter ]
That camp was worth every penny.
So, obviously, this is not
how Andrew Cuomo planned
to end his political career.
He was once the most
dominant, ruthless,
most Machiavellian force
in New York politics.
Now, he's just the latest
in a long line
of disgraced
New York politicians
who will inevitably
get photographed
by The New York Post
with a long, scruffy beard
and a Mets hat,
sloppily eating a dollar slice
on a bench in Central Park
by himself.
Central Park has a bench
specifically for that.
[ Laughter ]
If only there were a way to,
I don't know, lift his spirits.
Perhaps, I don't know,
a pep talk
from someone who knows
what he's going through.
-Hi, it's Rudy Giuliani
and I'm on Cameo.
If there's an issue of concern
that you want to discuss
or a story you'd like to hear
or share with me,
or a greeting
that I can bring to someone
that would bring happiness
to their day,
I would be delighted to do it.
[ Chuckling ]
It can be arranged.
We can talk.
Through the magic of Cameo.
Thank you.
-No, Rudy. Thank you.
I guess Rudy's last cameo
went so well,
he decided to give it
another go.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Giuliani ]
For an extra 50 bucks,
I'll tuck in my shirt.
Also, where is he?
Did he film that
in an IKEA showroom?
Why does everything
looks so chintzy?
Reminds me of action films
from the '80s
where the characters
would be arguing
in front of a set of shelves
that looked so cheap,
you'd think,
"Oh, someone's definitely
getting thrown into those."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, Rudy.
Sweet, sweet Rudy.
He has no idea what he's in for.
Right now, a prosecutor in the
Southern District of New York
is logging on to Cameo
and asking Rudy
to share the story of the time
he went to Ukraine
to dig up dirt
on a political opponent
to interfere
in a presidential election.
[ As Biden ]
This message is for Mr. DOJ.
I hear you're feeling
discouraged at work.
Well, let me tell you
about the time
my friend Don and I
cooked up a scheme
[ Laughter ]
to extort a foreign government
and got away with it.
Oh, it says here you want me
to read you
my text messages and emails.
Oh, hold on.
Someone's banging at the door.
Why are you yelling "Police!"?
There's no police in here.
[ Laughter ]
Now, Rudy's charging
$275 per video.
But, if you just wait a while,
you know,
he'll eventually
butt-dial you for free.
I mean, this guy,
this guy,
who was the personal lawyer
to the president
of the United States,
and, now, he's basically
panhandling
in the same place you can get
a "Happy Bat Mitzvah" message
from Jamie Farr.
Does that count
as a "M-A-S-H" reference?
You let us know.
[ Laughter ]
Now, I will say it took
a lot of self-control
on our part
not to buy a Cameo from Rudy
because, ultimately,
even if you're doing it
as a joke,
Rudy's still getting the money.
It's not like it's joke money.
I mean, Pizza Rat doesn't care
if the pizza's three days old.
He's just happy he found
something to eat,
especially something on-brand.
[ Laughter ]
Plus, we don't have $275
to throw away
on a dumb Cameo from Rudy
because we have to keep paying
Wally for all his lines.
In fact, Wally's so famous now,
he's doing his own Cameos.
-Hey, this message is
for Rudy G.
Keep going and don't let any
of those lame talk show hosts
get you down, buddy.
[ Laughter ]
-You're very good at it, Wally.
-Thank you very much.
-You're very good.
-Thank you.
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-And any money Rudy makes
from this
will presumably go
toward paying the legal bills
he's racked up from trying
to dig up dirt on Joe Biden
and trying to overthrow
the results of the election,
in part,
because his former client,
the guy he did all
that dirty work for,
Donald Trump,
refuses to help him.
The Daily Beast reported
this week that, even...
Wow, they're not even
acknowledging that it exists.
Rudy's closest friends
are all treating him
the way you treat your coworker
when you both get on the subway
at the same time
and you realize,
if you start a conversation now,
you're going to have
to sustain it
for the next 45 minutes.
In those situations,
I just close my eyes.
I pretend I'm asleep.
No wonder Rudy's doing Cameos.
Soon, he's going to have to pawn
off his precious belongings.
[ As Biden ]
This is a Yankees
World Series trophy.
"Sir, that's a Yankee Candle."
Oh, Rudy!
You done it again!
[ Laughter ]
And I'm betting
an acknowledgment
from Trump would help
because, I have to say, I follow
Rudy news pretty closely.
I had no idea -- no idea! --
he had a legal defense fund.
At this point,
I'm willing to bet
even Rudy's neighbors
have no idea he has one.
And I'm just spitballing, here.
If -- and it's a big if --
if he lived across the hall
from a guy,
I don't know, eating a bagel,
in a Yankees hat,
[ Laughter ]
that guy might say --
[ As Sandler ]
Oh, so Rudy needs money, huh?
That makes sense
because, yeah, the other day,
I saw him trying to stuff
Camel Cash into a parking meter.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, he filmed the whole
thing on Cameo.
Can you believe
this Yankees bullpen?
How many saves can you blow
in one game?
[ Laughter ]
What's that?
I know my robe's open.
[ Laughter ]
It's a free country.
Rudy and his allies
have apparently tried
to get Trump to help,
either by giving money
to Rudy's legal defense fund
or, at least,
drawing attention to it,
but Trump has refused.
I mean, were you surprised?
Trump's only drawn to people
who project strength
and confidence.
Meanwhile, if Rudy had
his own cologne,
it would be called...
Trump would never help
someone like that,
even though Rudy is facing
a mountain of legal bills
because he did
Trump's dirty work.
Among as many
other legal problems,
Rudy is also being sued
for defamation
by the election technology
firm Dominion,
the same company
that's also suing
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
for spreading insane lies
about the election.
Lindell, you might recall,
is so crazy,
he got kicked out of a meeting
of the Republican
Governors Association
and, at an event yesterday that
he billed as a Cyber Symposium,
Lindell spent a considerate
amount of time
complaining about how he got
kicked out of that meeting.
-If y'all remember,
I got kicked out
of the Republican
Governors Convention
because Doug Ducey
and Brian Kemp
were afraid I would talk to 'em.
I was invited there.
Now, we're going to talk
about the terrible media.
I was invited
to that convention.
Here's the real story behind it.
I get down there.
I got my things.
We're all going to head
to the governor's mansion
and a guy comes out
and he goes, "Mike,
you've been kicked out,"
and he goes,
"You've been uninvited."
I said, "What do you mean?"
He goes, "Something to do
with Brian Kemp and Doug Ducey."
Well, and I said,
"The whole event?"
He said,
"Yeah, the whole event."
-Everything about that
is perfect.
I especially love
that he wanted to clarify
if he'd been kicked out
of the whole event,
as opposed to just getting
kicked out of part of it,
and I bet that's not
the first time it happened.
[ As Lindell ]
I once got kicked out
of the quiet car on Amtrak
and said,
"Can I go to a regular car?"
They said, "You got to go
to the loud car."
Then, they opened the door
and they pushed me
out of the train.
[ Laughter ]
But I just hit the tracks
and I bounced right back up.
[ Laughter ]
Also, in what way was this
a cyber symposium?
From what I can tell,
he spent a lot of the time
complaining about getting
kicked out of other events.
Imagine going to see a man
who admits this is the only room
he's been allowed to stay in
and then, imagine
if he was also asked
to leave that room,
and then refused.
-They attacked me.
They buried it.
You think about that.
-They got something they want
to show you offstage here.
-Okay, I guess we have
something offstage.
So, we're livestreaming, though.
So, you want to talk?
-I think we're going to --
I think we're set up for a break
and maybe we're going
to talk a little bit.
Right when we get back there,
we're going to go into --
-No, we're not going on a break.
Put up that movie again.
Run the movie.
There's no breaks.
We're streaming 72 hours,
livestreaming,
so, around the world.
This never stops.
You guys can go eat.
That's fine, but I ain't eating.
-[ Laughs ]
-I'm staying up here
for 72 hours
before they ruin our signal.
[ Laughter ]
-Amazing. First,
he got kicked out of the
Republican Governors Convention,
and then, they tried to drag him
out of his own Cyber Symposium.
Next, they're going to kick him
off the board of MyPillow.
"Mike, we're just not sure
a guy who says he's going to
stay up and livestream for three
days straight without breaks
is a guy you want
to buy a pillow from."
[ As Lindell ]
I can't sleep, anyway.
MyPillow is filled
with fire ants and broken glass.
Now, let me get out there,
so I can talk about cy-bear.
[ Laughter ]
Run the movie,
"The Blues Brothers"!
[ Laughter ]
Also, real slick move, there,
by the other guy,
to try to get him offstage --
"We got something to show you."
[ Laughter ]
Were they trying to lure him
under a box held up by a stick
like in "Looney Tunes."
[ Laughter ]
"Come on, Mike. Mike, c'mere.
Ooh, look, Mike.
We got something very special
over here to show.
Come on, Mike!
Come here.
Quick!
Quick, throw the tarp on him!
Strap him down!
Keep your hands away
from his mouth!
He will bite you!"
[ Laughter ]
This has been
a week of consequences
for some of the most
corrupt people in politics.
In Cuomo's case,
he's slinking away in disgrace
after facing a reckoning
for his years of harassment,
bullying, and ruthlessness.
And, for Rudy and Lindell,
they're finding out what happens
when you debase
and humiliate yourself
in service of a man
who never returns any loyalty
to the people
he demands it from.
Every day,
they embarrass themselves
and suffer new indignities
on Trump's behalf.
At this point,
Trump could order Rudy
to streak naked across the field
at Yankee Stadium
and Rudy would say...
-I would be delighted to do it.
[ Chuckling ]
It can be arranged.
We can talk.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.